foreign
[Music]
hey guys how's it going like And
subscribe you know what I mean we got to
get it going we got to get it popping
but yeah like And subscribe and uh leave
a comment what do you think we're going
to talk about today you don't know but
guess what the best thing about this
podcast is I don't know either so
welcome to another episode of
congratulations
[Music]
and she'd be printing she's printing yes
dude what are you printing
maybe she's not printing okay well
whatever we thought the printer was
going off it went off sometimes the
printer will just relax you know you'll
be hanging out and all of a sudden your
parental just got
and uh that's what just happened
nobody's printed something in weeks but
all good
um yes Chris Dalia here uh episode of
congratulations number 300 something man
uh when are we done you know oh I forgot
to wear these these weren't Calvin's
party I wanted to wear these because
they're very cool wow these are the
wow guess how comfortable these are you
know zero comfortable they're Minecraft
Minecraft sunglasses they heard the
where do they hurt the bridge my nose
and also my ear is great
um so yes I got the Minecraft sunglasses
on I will be in Minneapolis I will be in
uh Austin I will be in doing stand-up in
all these uh different places it's gonna
be crazy absolutely uh Midland uh Texas
Utah which is uh getting up there almost
sold out Salt Lake City then when it
comes to your boy we love it Milwaukee
uh Columbus Ohio and Cincinnati Ohio and
a bunch of different places go to
chrisley.com we're adding dates we'd be
adding we do be adding dude we're gonna
be adding dates uh different spots this
summer we're gonna do some casinos crazy
extra yaper scoop that up and then also
we're gonna do some dates in the fall uh
we don't want to tell anybody but
Nashville shhh
don't tell anyone
she's probably going to be doing some
some in Michigan
show chrisley.com but not yet but
they're not on sale yet but probably
going to be kind of do we're gonna do
Canada
where all the major cities and then
don't tell anybody it's a secret so uh
anyway uh yeah that's what's up we're
probably also going to be doing Virginia
don't tell anybody I have no idea what
my fan base is like in Virginia but it's
all good we did Tulsa dude and Tulsa uh
is going through something with the
economy but they still came out
it's all good they're talking about he
kept the seats wrong but not too warm
because they stood up at some points
um and yeah man Tulsa is a great venue
well these are the this is torture those
those sunglasses are torture who makes
these dude let me guess where they're
made let me guess what they're made not
trying to be a you know what I mean not
trying to be you know a certain way but
let me guess what they made they don't
even say it probably Taiwan
um
so got my hair cut feeling good uh I got
my hair cut because I'm shooting special
April 1st got my hair cut so it'll grow
in by the time it grows in it's going to
be looking absolutely Bang
dude you should honestly look at my
special just to see my haircut
um yeah got it cut and uh but yeah so
um I went to uh oh look I went to uh
different spots this week Where'd I go
it was the uh did I go to Tech where the
hell was I even I was in I know I was in
Tulsa before that Kansas City oh and
Springfield Missouri dude y'all ever
been to Springfield Missouri
you have oh yeah you have uh why is it
okay man when you go to Kansas City
all right and then you go to Springfield
Missouri and then you go to Tulsa you go
like this well
I'm not going to be having a whole lot
of fun
you know
you first of all there's two Kansas
Cities and you're like which which one
am I going to
because one of them is
actually cool because I say actually
because you think Kansas City thinks the
middle of nowhere whatever the [__]
and one of them is just one of them has
500 000 people and one of them has 100
000 people and it's just a lot of uh
what do you call it uh Indus industrial
[__]
now I went to the one that has 500 000
people and it was great had a good show
awesome go to Kansas City and had had a
fun time
and then I went to Springfield Missouri
and I go this is already a place I know
I can't wait to get out of
get to Springfield Missouri
and when I tell you it's the Dark Horse
city of America dude this place was on
and popping own and puppet and his own
own and Poppin and his own and popping
dude we went there it's got nice
old-fashioned diners it's got nice cool
uh areas that are really hip it's got an
Arts District it's got people that look
like they [__] know what's going on
they're smiling having a good time
they'll have a conversation with you
it's got people with cool dogs they
literally just have like a hot couple
like a dude and a chick walking around
with like a cool dog and you're like
what kind of dog is that and they're
like a mini boxer and you're like I've
never even seen one dude Springfield
Missouri now you don't think
Springfield's going to be good because
why Springfield there's about 50 of them
in America right when they don't know
what the name of town they go like this
Springfield and then they're like well
we haven't thought of something better
so yeah sure why not I mean every state
is a Springfield how many Springfields
are there in uh in America
but there is one in Missouri and we went
and we played a little thousand seat
Theater now I understand it's a little I
say it's a little if you're Brian Kellen
it's a huge venue but for me
shoulder to shoulder so
um we went to Springfield Missouri and
my God we stayed in a hotel and I go
like this Springfield Missouri you have
the business having a hotel like this
where are we Hollywood you've got no
business where are we Soho is this just
so great excuse me
Springfield Missouri we got going you
get the vandivert
hey we're at the Vandiver Hotel
we go to vandervoir hotel it's got a big
v on it you go in and you go oh you got
no business
you're getting a business being here
did the show was Bonkers got back and
this is what I did was sometimes I go
when the city's not going to be super
banging We're not gonna have a super
bang in time when I'm like well there's
probably not a place to go eat
afterwards so I say let's drive through
the night and go to the next city so
that's what I chose on doing I go hey I
say Enrique
I say let's set it up to where let's
leave Springfield and go to Tulsa after
the Springfield show because
Springfield's probably not going to be
on and popping
after the show go back to the hotel let
me tell you something dude thank God I
left because your boy would have got in
trouble dude
[Music]
the place was so on and popping it was
unbelievable dude I mean I would have
become an alcoholic I don't you know
what I mean like
it was so good so many people were there
I mean I'm talking to talk about chicks
okay dudes dudes I want to hang with man
like good looking dudes that smelled
nice not too nice though right
just so good
I was like let's go dude so we went and
we started to watch and we sat in a
uh what do you call it a um
a uh
one of those Sprinter vans and we went
we watched a TV show and they were like
what do we want to watch what bad thing
do we want to watch so I put on the
glory it's a number three show in
Netflix
and it's Korean and I said let's watch
it and I go oh no dude and we were so
hooked I got everybody hooked Lula got
hooked David Sullivan got hooked and now
I got a new show Whoopsie Daisy I got a
new show by mistake Whoopsie Daisy I'm
the type of girl for the new show on a
van
so I found that show great good and uh
and everybody's hooked on that show and
it's good
got the eyeballs right there can't
really see eyeballs right there because
I started doing this thing to Calvin hey
what's up dude and it's the best thing
in the world because I drew eyeballs on
him and he does it like this hi how's it
going and it's the cutest thing in the
world so it's all good but he loves it
and then he feeds it and they go oh and
I poop it out and he laughs a lot just
some dad stuff for you if you're a dad
that's how it goes
um but yeah we do hey what's up
no don't feed me and I go oh man I'm so
full and I sh and I and I pooped cheese
it and she he did he it's so I mean it
was it would be like he's watching Don
Rickles he's laughing so hard so um
so yeah Springfield was amazing Tulsa
was amazing uh and I I honestly I go
like this I'm driving through Tulsa and
I say man this place is going to be
really good in like 10 years and the
driver's like you said it and uh uh the
owner of the theater bought a parking
lot 10 years ago for 300 000 for a
hundred thousand dollars and he sold it
this uh last year for a million for
three million dollars and I go what and
David tell us Sullivan says hey man you
should buy a building and buy a building
hey Chris Bob building
by building and and fix it up and then
sell them I said I can't afford that he
says yes you can man so guess what
buying a building in Tulsa
hit up my buddy I hit up my man my my
business manager I was like can I buy a
building in Tulsa and he was like I'd
love to know what what your idea is he's
I mean he's just like man I really hope
Chris isn't serious but I might buy
building in Tulsa
because I'm telling you man Tulsa is
going to be one of the the best cities
maybe I'll just get a compound and we
can all do that I'll move the cult in
there and just kind of you know what I
mean
just kind of
you know chill in the building in Tulsa
just sitting
whatever dude I don't know I don't know
what you want from me man
but I'm super sore because I was working
out yeah yeah yeah yes I did oh sorry I
thought somebody asked me if I was doing
burpees
I did dude I did I did burpees and then
I I oh dude oh what no wait sorry I
thought you asked you so I did a free
hand no I did it with weights dude and I
would go down and I come up and I'd go
down dude and I did it with David
Sullivan dude he ain't [__] I killed it
man
uh and then the next day I did split
what split squat squirrel
bulgarians split squats can't say it
um and then and then chin ups dude you
know your boy does real nice with the
chin UPS so uh and there were some like
eight-year-old kids doing the treadmill
and they were like so loud and they were
on a company by a by an adult and David
called [__] downstairs and told on
him oh dude he told on him and the
security camera but you guys can't be
here and they said David you're an old
man and he said nah man I thought they
were gonna get they were gonna get hurt
man they were on the they were on the on
the treadmill I thought they were gonna
get hurt
I was like dude you're an old man but I
liked it man
he's too helpful
I don't understand man he's too helpful
God when we get in the cars and the
drivers are and then he's just like so
what's like where I know we're [__]
you know the driver we're in the driver
I bring a dude on tour with me you know
he works with he works on the tour and
then he's chilling he's one of my very
good friends
he's a great actor I don't know why why
he wants to be on a tour with me but
you know he does the [__]
award-winning
movies but he loves it he loves he's all
about that lifestyle dude he never sit
still but
he always wants to go somewhere so we're
on the tour and he was like Hey man
we'll be in the car and I'll just be
like so what's what is it in Tulsa you
do that
what do we do in Tulsa you got the that
got the ballet here right just like that
and the guy's like yeah I know I've
never been to the ballet I'm like David
dude he's like well man I want to ask
more questions well just chill do it
um you got that friend that asked too
much too many questions that guy could
take a hike right
a guy asked too many questions it's like
dude
what are you asking for you're just
making conversation
people who just make conversation you
know
what are you running from
you go to a coffee shop you sit down you
drink a coffee and then this person next
to you is just like it's crazy out there
right with the thing and you're well
they're like oh now we're talking about
some [__]
nah because it used to have a mailbox
right there and ever since and then they
got rid of it you know the parade would
come through and and you're just sitting
and you're like uh yeah you know how
selfish it is to make [__] just take
for a stranger to be like
sodia
oh here we go
that's what I want to do when someone
small talks me
as soon as they open their mouth oh here
we go
this is for you
now I'm in your world right because I
like to be in my world man
and somebody takes me into their world
oh here we go huh
here we go
I remember one time I went to this strip
club it was like ah man I was like 26.
it was a stripper there she was really
hot and then uh at this coffee shop I
saw her and I was like oh [__] I know
you like people think that I'll like be
embarrassed you know
if you see someone in this trip like how
many guys be embarrassed you see a
stripper that you were at a strip club
with and then you saw them later on in
real life you go oh I don't wanna you
hide from them like it's your teacher at
a grocery store
no I'm me dude I walk right up to that
person hey teach
or hey I remember you and they go oh
yeah oh hey I say hey what's up we
should I remember the band I was I must
have been 28 or something
I said we should hang some time what's
your number dude she gave me her she
goes like all right here give me your
phone and she typed in her number and I
go ah cool and then I looked at it later
and it was like [__] it started with
like a two no numbers it was fake
it was like two five six six six six six
six six six six six six six they were
like 25 sixes in it and I go oh man I
certainly been mad hadn't I
okay
dude wonder what she's doing
yeah she probably got fat
it's what we do on the defense dude
that's what we do we get defensive my
baby we get the offensive that's what we
do told me
um I wish her well though forget her
name never know her real name as a
matter of fact I think it's spice but um
yeah dude so we're having a good time
hearing the congratulations and uh I'm
back from the road and I'm good dude got
back to the got back from the road there
were 1900 people in my house had no idea
why my wife got organizers and let me
tell you man if you never got organizers
dude it is [__] worth it dude I
opened up a drawer and I go
um look how beautiful
but then I go like this but where are
the things I wanted right
because where are they and my wife is
just like we put them over here in a
different drawer so now I gotta relearn
the house great dude
gotta relearn the house yes super
annoying but also super clean okay
there's also five of them in there right
now doing it I have no idea how much it
costs
good
it's gonna be so much yeah yes
this is just chandelia spent way too
much to organize his house
um but yeah dude just gonna be
absolutely
recalculus
um with how much it's going to be but
have no idea but it's gonna be so clean
dude throwing away so much dude I love
throwing away so much [__] my OCD goes
like this because I also do it was like
this no
my OCD no
but then my person
comes in and goes like yo yo yo yo we
got this OCD we got this I'm covering my
City's like this no no my brain's like
this no we got this OCD because the
[__] I you know how I got ready dude
I was gonna be a hoarder I was gonna be
a hoarder do you know that that was in
the cards for me oh that was in the
cards for me dude when I watch hoarders
I go oh oh we missed out on making that
episode about me because I nipped it in
the bud I remember the moment I nipped
being a hoarder in the butt and now I'm
not a hoarder and I did that mentally
knowing with my werewithal figuring it
out at as a 14 year old I made the
decision to not be a hoarder and that
was the most nip in it and the buddest
thing I ever did in my life and let me
tell you what happened dude I used to
collect everything everything I was
Hector The Collector just everything I
used to collect everything dude people
would be like yo Chris why do you keep
these and I would be like why not man
you got to keep those because
what if and they go what are they gonna
say why I say what if one day that was
my answer
I kept stuff even that food came in oh
dude he was gonna be a hoarder I kept
McDonald fries like dude when they would
do a special thing like a like the
Batman Forever thing when they when it
was like McDonald's come and get your
favorite Happy Meal Batman Forever I
wouldn't even get I would get a Happy
Meal just to get the the fry holders
they have one without killing or one
with Tommy Lee Jones and one with Jim
Carrey and I had them all dude and I
kept them and they had the greasy ass
fries [__] in it dude
I'm a collecting fool though I did it
and then one day one day I looked at it
when I was 14 and I go like this this is
never going to end
and I threw away [__] all of it and
it hurt
as I was thrown it away it was just the
soundtrack Everybody Hurts Jim Carrey
fries
sometimes little Matchbox cars
special edition Drew bled so [__]
lunchbox Everybody Hurts
tossed them summed
hold on for no reason he says it
hold on for no reason not about holding
on at all but said it anyway everybody
Hurts
Hyundai Tercel could say that doesn't
matter what still sells many copies
songs are [__] so um
you know what songs are [__] dude
how I learned it you know when I knew
songs were [__] when the guy from
Goo Goo Dolls goes how may
we're gonna get married
what you're seeing is who you are and
who you are it's beautiful oh May for no
reason oh May and then someone asked him
in an interview who's May and he says I
don't know I just sang it man dude songs
are [__] yes figured it out could
have been a hoarder
so anyway I threw them all away and now
I'm not a hoarder and sometimes when we
go to throw stuff away even still as a
42 year old man I'm young as [__] but as
a 42 year old man I go like this no no
but then my OCD goes remember the fries
and I do
and I get rid of all this [__] and then
what do I do when my wife says do you
need these I get pissed because guess
what I don't need them but now I look at
them and I think I need them but just
get rid of them because I would never
think of them ever again
do you know what I'm saying man
do you guys know what I'm saying for
real my wife goes like did you want
these and I said what she says well
there's a lot of childhood stuff in here
was my childhood good yeah it was it was
good it was good on the surface was I
dealing with demons yes toss it all
always had a fear of abandoned
abandonment why that's for me not for
you touch it
but what is it like pictures of old
dances in high school what is it
pictures of me doing a drawing like in
[__] sixth grade of of super man at
one time they had told me to color a
Superman for homework and my uncle made
me put like Jerry curls on them and
colored him like Michael Jackson and
then in the in the in the bubble in the
in the speaking bubble it said he he
and my uncle and my uncle and my uncle
let me turn it in like that
that's really funny actually can't wait
to do that [__] with Calvin honestly
[__] but um
so uh so yeah I said I would never know
if it was gone she was asking me about
mugs what about this one it says Late
Night with Seth Meyers this was the one
you got for late night Seth and I was
like yeah I actually like that one we're
back sorry uh we we uh our stuff skipped
and everything
the the [__] power went out what do
you need to know it's fine uh honestly
uh I got robbed and everyone took
everything we had to get new equipment
it doesn't matter dude but uh we're back
um so yeah my wife's asking me about
mugs and [__] it's all good it was great
awesome it's awesome when people are
asking about mugs and so but it's just
like I don't need to know that's my
whole point I guess is what I'm saying I
don't know if it skipped out earlier
before this or not but I'll say it again
like you need to
I don't need to know
you know how much [__] you need in life
honestly
things it's the things it's like what do
you need what are things like I was
talking to somebody who was at Lulu and
she was like
yeah my my sister or something got rid
of my baby pictures and now I don't have
any baby pictures and stuff and it's
like that so that's honestly what they
tell you when they created you in a lab
but I don't know I feel like she's a
real human because I love her and she's
great but
um
yeah it's like uh
the things that you need
I was actually putting Calvin to bed
last night and um he'll go back from the
road put on a I put in a bed and um he
came out to the room
to my room and he was like Dad
he was like Dad and I walked in and I
said and I looked
and he was in his closet like peeking
out of it and I was like what are you
doing he was like what are you doing I
was like we gotta go to bed buddy I put
him to bed and I laid with him for a
little bit and he was like so happy that
I was laying with him and then he was
like um
he was like I I I he I said whatever
came up that I was at work for the past
like three days
and
um and he said
yeah uh
he said what did you do at work and I
said
well I had to be at work and he said why
he's asking why a lot and I said because
I had to because when I go to work you
get money when you go to work and we
need money to to pay for things and he
said why and I said well we need money
to pay for honestly anything
um uh food toys
um this house that we live in clothes
and I said we got to get money for that
I said you use money and then I said to
him I said you pretty much use money for
everything and then I realized well it's
not everything so I said you pretty much
use money for everything except the
things that are really important like
and I said uh family and love like you
don't need money to buy family or love
and he said well I mean I I get it like
in Miami you do but like not like in
real life and then he and he said uh
what is family and love
and I said well family are people who
are close to you they're like a part of
you like me and Mom Uncle Matt pop pop
Gammy Kiki you know that's his other
grandma's name
and uh and he said
that's family and I said yeah and he
said what is love and I said love is
like and I was like how the hell do you
describe this period but then how do you
describe it to a three-year-old and I
said I said love is basically
you know when like you're in mommy's
arms or when you're really close with me
and we're cuddling and it's really happy
you know that feeling you feel and he
said yeah and I said that's what love is
and he said that's what love is and then
I said Yup and then my son said
what is the mystery of love
he just said what's the mystery okay I
don't first of all I just explained what
love is which means he doesn't know what
love is which is like then how the [__]
does he know what mystery is
you don't know what love is how do you
know what mystery is so I said what's
the mystery of love and he said yeah and
I said well buddy that's something that
you got to figure out for yourself
and I walked in a room and Krista was
there I was like man I did not expect
for that conversation to go like that
now I'm [__] thinking about the
goddamn mystery of love in my bed by
myself
can't sleep anyway
and I ended up falling asleep but yeah
so it's like those are the things that
you need
family love in them and then whatever
the mystery is but like so that's what I
was doing with them I'm talking about
the Persian [__] A bunch of stuff it's
like just get rid of it man get rid of
it see you later
um anyway dude so that's what happened
that's what happened in my life so far
and the people are still here figuring
it out uh what to get rid of and what
not to and I hope she doesn't ask me
many questions dude I'm gonna get rid of
so many clothes
um
they have a uh what do you call it oh
the Oscars dude who won hey I don't know
hey the Oscars past 10 years who won yo
you got me the only thing I know about
this year's Oscars is that Asian guy who
played the little Asian in The Goonies
and [__] won something
you know
what are the movies that won in the last
10 years I don't know Coda was one I
think maybe
what other ones you got me to that movie
1917 win
you got me has anyone seen any of the
Oscar winners twice in the last 10 years
or did they just go yeah that one was a
[__] real good movie would you watch
again no no
no who's in it guess what
I don't know some British woman named
Emma something you know
and that's it then a newcomer that's
French
that Western Front movie ah what's that
is it even a guy or a girl in it no clue
and I've seen the person's face nine
times in the on the Billboards we got a
helmet on no clue
who's in movies now
Will Smith is in some I think right
Keanu Reeves still does movies that are
like he's already done before
but like the new movies
I don't know
let's see who won Brendan Frazier won
right and everyone's acting like ah
finally my guy you know
I see people just online like see
everything comes full circle fun every
this Oscars was all about what comes
full circle see finally the guy who was
in Goonies 90 hundred years ago finally
he got representation finally Brendan
Frazier finally Brenda Frazier let's not
forget brain Brayden Frazier has about
100 million dollars you know final dude
how many people right now how many
actors how many A-list actors are like
no how many
man I tell you what that movie The Whale
first of all looks
he looks like he is so good in that
movie
looks
so boring dude I would watch I will
honestly dude I would I want to cut
together that movie the the good parts
I'll watch that dude I bet it's so good
and so boring when I watch the best
movies of all time are the most boring
don't get me wrong but a guarantee when
I see I saw the clip I saw a little
YouTube short of the whale I go that's
all I need to see because I saw Brendan
Fraser with the [__] nose thing and
the oxygen tank because he's fat as [__]
and he was just like I need to do one
thing in my life and I was like dude
okay all right I saw it did you see the
whale yeah so now people say did you say
well I said yeah dude was great in it
this is the whole movie kinda it was a
YouTube short but
so fat too dude make honestly
don't make him not fat in it it's all
good make him like half of that it's
fine we'll still be think he's great now
so many act dude that movie is gonna
birth so many bad movies do you
understand do you understand now that we
gave him the Oscar we're [__] over the
next 10 years we got to see so many of
these idiot actors in like fat suits
with like prosthetic noses there's gonna
be somebody who does a movie and they're
gonna be like I'll chop off my limbs
dude it's gonna be so bad
we got to watch [__] Michael B Jordan
now in a fat suit because this happened
you know what I'm saying and it's like
dude the whole reason why we go see
Michael Jordan movies is because of his
shoulders
now we gotta watch because [__] Gary
Oldman did it a little bit when he did
the movie with that was the bad movie
the where he played uh the hell was it
exactly these are like the only movies
that he does exactly
Gary Oldman played a movie where he just
does so much breathing in between
talking and he's in he's just like
you're gonna win an Oscar because he did
that
right because he got they put I'm gonna
put jowls on me and he got jowls and
[__] and he's and we takes place in the
1920s whatever the [__] it was
and now Brendan Fraser was like ah I
play a fact and now we gotta watch now
dude
mark my words if who would it be
um
oh uh the guy who's in Aaron brockledge
Aaron Eckhart dude if we don't see an
Aaron Eckhart movie an Aaron Eckhart
vehicle that was made for 1.5 there's a
budget for the movie that
was made for 1.5 million dollars that
was shot no doubt for real that was shot
in um uh what's the [__] place that
where you get a lot of tax back
I bet it would be shot in Oklahoma or uh
or New Mexico or Louisiana
the budget is 1.5 million dollars
and uh
and uh and and what who would I say [__]
who is it Aaron eckhart's in it if he
doesn't ugly up his face with
prosthetics or get in a fat suit in the
next three years and try to go for an
Oscar I will quit this [__] podcast
this podcast won't be any more I'll just
do Lifeline I'll quit golden hour I'll
do I'll only do Lifeline with my brother
there's no way it's not going to happen
it's gonna be so and there's going to be
so men and they're gonna be so bad dude
I wish they just called that movie fatty
for real
by the way how the [__] is it okay for
Woody Harrelson to make that movie with
the people with Down Syndrome and the
Fairly Brothers what's that movie called
Champions or something how'd they make
it that's just awesome
you know why because Woody Harrelson is
already safe he's grandfathered in and
he's he's deemed lovable you know what
I'm saying like Keanu Reeves could you
know oh you know Keanu Reeves could
literally make a movie like about
killing a a whole race of people and
people be like well you know it's Keanu
you once someone is deemed lovable done
dude
uh that's what Woody Harrelson is he
made a movie about a bunch of people
with Down Syndrome that the Fairly
Brothers wrote and directed I think
and and there's a joke in it where a guy
with Down Syndrome is like yeah I'm your
homie with the extra chromie
and it's like how'd you do it
how'd you do it it's 2023. dude how did
you do it when I say it now when I just
said it right now we got demonetized and
I'm just talking about the movie that
came out
crazy right
um
did them in that movie called Champions
nobody's gonna see it thank God too if
too many people saw it get canceled for
sure
um
but the Oscars are such a such a bunch
of stroke
it's just a bunch of stroking you know
man I was talking about this with my
friend David you know and I'm just like
what would it take for me to go to the
Oscars and I know people would be like
yo you don't like Hollywood now because
of everything that happened to you but
honestly
my nightmare to go to the Oscars even
back then I I would only go if I was
nominated for best person in the world
and I and and like not even
best actor I wouldn't I'd like Tom
Cruise didn't go this year and I'm just
like attaboy although [__] you know
like it even matters goddamn Tom Cruise
and [__] Mr Hollywood [__] it
my point is that it's it's such a stroke
Fest
and that's the thing too it's like
nominate the movies that are that are um
nominate the movies that are uh
critically acclaimed and [__] but then
don't nominate Top Gun 2 dude
right it's like dude the way you're
gonna do it the Oscars nobody's been
watching the whole over the years
nobody's been watching because of the
movies like Coda and [__] movies that
nine 95 people have seen
and then and then you got the nerve to
Top Gun bro
I mean not honestly nominate [__] uh
Suicide Squad like who like what are you
doing choose a lane I did what it
doesn't matter
nominate Nick Cannon's new game show
where where he tries to get [__]
someone pregnant have you seen about
this he's gonna have a new game show
where the game show is the winner of it
gets to
have his next baby
uh
dude it's good I swear to God it's
called insemination it's not called that
but I don't know what it's called but oh
my god dude hey dude world
bye bye Nick Cannon will star a new game
show it's called who's having my baby
hey
world
catch you later
hey world
catch you later World dude
that's a bad game show
oh okay so look what are they gonna do
what what's the game hey we're gonna ask
question all right here we go contestant
number one what's you know
what's the square root like what the
[__] are they gonna ask
it's fake it's not real
yeah was it an April Fool's thing
it's part of a different show that he
has with Kevin Hart
oh dude that's the thing about Kevin
Hart I forgot he does things like that
dude like what's Die Hard your heart
you know
they're making a die-hard too but John
Travolta and well what is that that came
out I didn't know about it
we're uh
where Kevin Hart was doing the [__]
thing with where he plays a version I
don't know dude the nerve of these
[__] love Kevin Hart big fan of Kevin
Hart love Kevin Hart but to have it I
was looking at the description it was
like Kevin Hart plays a version of
himself dude he's always playing a
version of himself
you know
he's not the one in the fat suit playing
the whale
he will be
um all right well that's fake thank god
dude I would have left world
I would have left the world
the Oscars let's go back to the Oscars
the outfits are just
I hate the I I
just like it's sad to see these people
who was it Olivia
who's the other one not man
wild she came in like a [__] swimsuit
that like if you legitimately if you
were at a hotel the staff would come and
be like you actually have to put
something else more on than that
and she just went with like her titties
out
to the Oscars and then the the also the
other woman from Euphoria who's gonna be
the new Hunger Games when she went with
she dude her dress was a feather across
her tits
she just goes like this oh gotta get
ready for the Oscars
let's go dude
it's bad
all good but and here's the other thing
too because nowadays you can't be like
what the [__] is she doing because it'd
be like oh you're body shaming or nah
how
and I know when I say that you get all
sorts of slack oh hey you can't [__]
whatever yeah oh good the Oscars though
you're treating it like Instagram
dude we get it but you're not on well
you're you're not on Santa Monica
Boulevard outside of Pinches Tacos
how dude you're at that you had a red
carpet why you can't sound
all good big fans of your work you're
great Olivia Wilde think you're a great
actress on the Oscars and the red carpet
wow all good
I get it dude I don't want to shame you
do it but if I went with a feather over
my [__]
I know it's a double standard but it's
all good and I don't care I ultimately
don't care honestly I think everyone
should go to the Oscars naked for real
I want to go just like holding holding
just hold him
dude the Oscars won't be [__] I
guarantee one day the Oscars it will be
the the whatever the actresses will come
up and she'll have a guy that she hired
just with his arm just holding her
titties like this and went to while they
walk
who are you wearing and she just goes
that hit that guy
and who are you
God you want to talk hi um Olivia Wilde
is wearing me my name is Barry
um
yeah
oh really
are you a designer no no we met uh
outside of pizza's tacos she uh she
hired me basically
all right you hired me
it's just me hey
[Laughter]
me with the [__] who's the one from
the the movie The Help
Octavia Spencer I'm just like
Octavia
she wants to know who you're with can I
talk me crystally I'm on podcaster
um
yeah dude what's wrong with everyone I
don't know we're not getting any better
though I know I know I get it like still
it's better to live now than it is like
in the Dark Ages but also Dark Ages
um
I don't know dude anymore
this is uh the thing that I wanted to
talk about here we go on uh the popular
podcast Congratulations by the way these
are the movies that were
um
the last 15 Best Picture winners every
everywhere everything and everybody or
whatever the [__] Coda Nomad land which
was Jesus I did not see but I know
that's horrible parasite which was good
you watch that once green book which I
saw a clip of the other day where uh
Vigo Mortensen is like so good in it
talking all Brooklyn and [__] and he's
uh he's like from
where is he from Australia or some or
British
yeah
is he American
whatever it is he was like yo yo what
the [__] you doing I'm like wow he's
doing it well the shape of water would
never see it Moonlight saw it would I
mean the fact that that one best picture
is pretty pretty crazy Spotlight which
was that one with the one with Mark
Ruffalo
bird man never saw it I would watch that
12 years of slave was good but only see
it once Argo didn't see it my friends in
it don't want to see it out of hate the
artist absolutely a joke that won best
picture there's no words in it King
speech
for two hours The Hurt Locker was good
love Jeremy Renner huge huge fan Slumdog
Millionaire one because of guilt
um and uh yeah dude I just basically
don't know who would ever see uh those
movies more than once but it's all good
so this is the clip I wanted to see uh
um
when do you have your hopes up for
anyone
um
no one in particular what are you
wearing tonight then
um so tell me what does it feel like to
be in glass on
the Thriller how fun is it to shoot
something like that well I'm barely in
it I'm in it for about three seconds
yeah
okay all right okay oh but but you
showed up and you had fun didn't you uh
almost snag-headed the movie edit the
experience so hey it's what's his name
[__] uh the other James Bond guy
what's his name
Daniel Craig hey Craig
just hates him so much oh great we got
the [__] James he would call him
James Bond on the set you know hey Bond
go over here we got to be over here and
just so dick about it you know dude dick
why is he so thick and I said that to my
friends and then a lot of my friends
were like well she was asking dumb as
[__] questions and I'm like yo it's on
network team dude
BS dumbass questions who are you wearing
well I wouldn't know either but you
don't be a dick that's so dick also
especially that guy got Second Chances
and [__] you know I remember when we was
having sex with that
and so um but it's all good but like and
like
man he says oh you know he's so pissed
dude
he's pretty handsome still though huh
that is so crazy to be eh dick for no
reason
oh yeah I showed up he had fun I almost
so dick
I feel like
um
that would have been me on my trajectory
uh anyway I uh
I think that this here
speaking of [__] tits out at the
Oscars in Berlin
they're allowing women to go topless in
public swimming pools That's crazy dude
huh it's actually not though like if you
were to if you just were a cane to Earth
and then all of a sudden
saw people naked in the swimming pool
you wouldn't think anything about it you
know but the fact that we have such you
know the societal norms and [__] uh here
we go
BBC News
women will soon be allowed to swim
topless in Berlin's public pools after a
ruling by the city's authorities
authorities that's hilarious dude
okay everyone gather around let's figure
this out here we've got a vote you want
to see the titties or not I vote Yes you
know a lot of them are really nice
Berlin though where's that uh Germany
fad you want dude oh so here we go all
right so
here we go again every three months we
uh every three months we decide to have
this uh we see we have his titties out
so we're going to have pool here uh and
uh we were wondering since the new pool
is coming in do you want to just do a
Vista class I would like a personally to
have it there you know the thing is we
take the class uh off of the titties uh
what we can do is um use the extra class
not as if we have it together my boner
you know so anyway I'll be good so here
we go yes I vote Yes I'd like to see
them uh bouncing around yeah you know
especially floating in the in the water
right so um would be nice you know
floating in the water Dali painting with
the clock right it's kind of like melted
all over the pool are we joking but
anyway so we're going to have some
titties afterward I vote Yes huh hands
up well not just one looks like way
you know what about two so let's um
anyway
it comes after a woman who was thrown
out of an open air pool for sunbathing
topless took legal action cable yeah we
can't do it until you can do it you know
what I mean
a second woman said she was told to
cover up while at an indoor pool in
December well yeah I can't do it I can
do it you know
authorities agreed that they had been
victims of discrimination discrimination
because oh dude they're just trying to
pop but dude they're just horny dudes oh
yeah yeah no we agrees that's his
discrimination of course that is a great
take it off honestly you can show you
downstairs area too if you want to
authorities agree they have been victims
of discrimination instead of all
visitors to Berlin pools were now
entitled to Go Topless wow dude
I would get
um
plastic surgery and put a penis on my
chest and just have no shirt on my chest
and then the penis will be out and I'd
be like hey dude you said it's cool for
the topless the Titans the decision will
be welcomed by those here who Champion
what's known as
frico per culture fickle but culture
free body culture yeah but then when it
comes to penises it's a different story
right for our visitors to Germany
because people think when penises are
out everyone's gonna get murdered you
know
Farm visitors to Germany are often
surprised and sometimes downright
disconcerted by the side of naked
Germans Frolic in its Lakes snoring in
its Parks wow dude you could be naked in
a park imagine the Uproar in America and
some dude just sitting with a floppy
penis just
but this is a country where it considers
public nudity is some settings to be
both appropriate and healthy healthy you
know
they just tricked the women that's what
happened
people just tricked women into be easy
it's coming around people are like I
want to be body free with my body and
then they just trick them yeah yeah for
sure this was by Design let your tits
out
[Music]
whoops sorry bumped into your titties
tricked you here's some lemonade anyway
go swimming
yes we all vote for that yes
where's the bar downstairs area too
that's discrimination too
turn around let's see what it looks like
in there
[Laughter]
oh
I always stop there right why are we
stopping the butt Loop right look and
don't say
that's discrimination too unzip
anyway
what
I just was saying if I was
discriminations that's why I took my
pants off started fixing my penis
I wasn't yanking I was just this I was
just
fixing it I had to put it up because it
was hurting because it was down and then
got directional
it's been a while since we've done
misconnections no it hasn't been but
let's do miss connections
um
we got this
I missed the girl I'd spoil Long Beach
and why is spoil spelled like that with
a zero and a one not the [__] you
know thing that's gonna get it flagged I
am classy respect of Tupac wrote this I
am classy is easy why respectful with a
z and looking with a zero for a new
friend
sad dude this guy wants to
what's up with that dude I was thinking
about that today actually about like men
who just kind of like are are s our
single Perpetual bachelors and just like
older and have just money and know that
the women that they're with are not with
them for love but only for money and I I
I I bet I I go there are definitely
different people for with different
feelings on that situation when they're
it if they are that guy right like if
you're that guy like would you be okay
with it if you're a 60 year old because
my whole thing is
and people are like you don't want to
die alone dying alone is fine dying
alone is fine you're gonna be dead soon
but when you're in your last 20 years of
life alone that [__] can be lonely you
know so it's like would you just be cool
with because I got buddies who are like
55 and stuff and they're single and
that's okay but pretty soon you're gonna
be 65 you're not gonna be able to find
someone so are you gonna find someone in
the next 10 years and they're gonna have
kids and then if you don't want kids
okay but do you really not want kids or
are you just being on the defense
because you had such a rough go early on
in life that now you're like nah I'm not
doing that [__] subjecting anyone to my
to a [__] to this world when I had a
rough go right so it's like
are you okay with being that old and
just like being a jet Setter if you're
rich and then like
spending money on having your girl come
see you when you know she doesn't really
love you she's just with you because
you're stacking dude it's a real I
wonder you probably just trick yourself
into it you do you're doing you gotta be
delusional and that's okay by the way
it's okay we're all delusional about
certain things
Kristen said she handed me something the
other day and I swear she never handed
it to me and she said she did and I said
no no she didn't and she's like I prom I
would go I would I would I would
absolutely
put a gun in my head tell you I gave it
to you and I was like well maybe she
didn't give it to me so it's like if
people are forget that and then they're
Deluge if people are delusional about
certain things I swear she didn't hand
it to me
[Laughter]
it's like if you could forget that [__]
you could forget oh this person doesn't
really let me [__] it
she loves me and fly him out and just
like buy him an apartment and this is
like it what is that you know
that's what says that's what Eliza
[__] are doing right I don't
know can you get away with that and and
still feel okay because the whole thing
about yeah but you got to feel your
feelings and really understand what
you're doing in your life and I
understand but it's like do you or can
you just ride it until you die
right
because I never used to feel my feelings
at all
and now I do and my therapist is like
you got to feel your feelings you gotta
actually you know you got to do this
it's better for you in the long run and
I'm like okay I'll take your word for it
why am I crying all the time though
got super deep but um
here's another one Johnny where are you
Johnny would come over and we would
chill and play games like Zip
what the [__] is zip missed the big fun
huh we just got sexual
oh
not him but you are young fit and
interested being a new buddy hit me up
hey okay but explain zip
what a zip is it a sex game let's look
it up
Johnny would come over and we would
chill and play games like Zip
game zip
is that like a that sounds like a Bop It
game
play zip
oh well a player clasped with her hands
with thumbs raised
index fingers pointing to an adjacent
person like like like this or like that
somebody they'd probably put their penis
in there a little bit
I mean you know
BJ where did you go oh wow hopefully
that's a person's name how about the
fact that some people's name it's like
Brian Johnson and they go by BJ
that's crazy
your name might as well be deep throat
I don't know where he is we used to
finish each other's sentences it's been
so hard lately I'm sad
in Palmdale no doubt no doubt Palmdale I
don't know where he is BJ where did you
go I don't know where he is we used to
finish each other's sentences it's been
so hard lately
that's a suicide note honestly
dude I would do my suicide note on
Craigslist for real
that would be great
World under it World hey it's been nice
knowing you bye oh that guy that's
actually really sad not and not funny um
all right here we go here's another one
yeah well dropped my vegetables wow um
can I have yours spelled y-o-r-e-s wow
so bad dude white meat on white meat
and then encaps any vegetables
and then G for G what's G for G
gay for gay
guy for guy I don't know you know what
so the innuendo just don't even just you
know
where is my Straight buddy Los Angeles I
lost contact with you and I'm hoping to
find you here did you move back in town
hey text to Mom
I left contact with you who are these
people that go around not having
people's numbers
guys who do so much crazy sex don't have
numbers I guess
that's it for the episode on YouTube if
you want to get the raw the uncut the
episode the actual extended episode uh
go to my patreon patreon.com crystalia
and also you get a free episode every
month and uh sometimes we say the
bangers from patreon so go over there
there's like 24 episodes on patreon that
you can't access uh but you can for just
six bucks so go over to Chris uh
patreon.com crystalline.com for those
thanks
[Music]
you're welcome
thank you
[Music]
foreign